hi i'm matt cooperberg
from the department of urology and
epidemiology and biostatistics
at the ucsf helen de la family
comprehensive cancer center in san
francisco
and it's a pleasure to share some
thoughts with you today about the topic
of getting under the hood of racial
disparities
in prostate cancer which is an
area of growing importance in research
and i think a lot of the lessons
which are evident in prostate cancer
have pretty broad applicability across
oncology and so just to start off here
i'm painting a picture of the
epidemiology and where prostate cancer
stands in 2020
it remains by far the most common cancer
diagnosed among
men with over 191 000 diagnoses expected
this year
it also remains the second most common
cause of mortality among men over 33 000
cases
expected to be lethal now of course the
number of diagnoses still
far exceeds the number of lethal cases
and it's really important to look at the
way these trends have evolved
over the years because this is the
background against which the disparity
story
needs to be understood so the incidence
of prostate cancer
has varied quite a bit over the decades
with practices around psa
based early detection so in the early
1990s when psa really hit the clinical
forefront incidents spiked as a whole
set of prevalent cases which had been
undiagnosed in the community were
suddenly diagnosed
then a study state was found throughout
most of the 90s and early 2000s
and then after a series of
recommendations from the us preventive
services task force
cast a increasingly
cold bucket of water on the psa
screening program across primary care
in the u.s incidence rates plunged to
the lowest level
in 2014 that they had seen since the
1980s now this of course is not because
prostate cancer had disappeared
from the from the population if anything
men in 2010s are living longer than they
were in the 1980s are less likely to die
early of
cardiac disease we should be seeing more
prostate cancer and yet the incidence
rates plunged and this was really
because of
profound drops in psa early detection
programs
after first the 2018 and then 2012
recommendations from the uspstf
mortality rates in the meantime where we
have data going back to the 1930s
had really been very slowly rising
throughout the
20th century i'm really peaking around
1990
to 1995 or so and then have been falling
pretty progressively over a 20-year
period
at the fastest rate of any cancer except
for lung cancer
now we know this decline in lung cancer
is attributable almost entirely to
smoking cessation programs
the decline in prostate cancer is a
little bit controversial but there's
really little argument that at least
30 to 50 percent of this decline is
directly attributable to early detection
programs
and it's concerning that in the most
recent years of the data we actually see
the mortality decline
stabilizing or perhaps even reversing
for the first time
this is not entirely due to the drop in
screening but there's no question
that as mortality rates increase if we
continue to drop down in terms of
screening we will see
more prostate cancer mortality now why
is this important for disparity well
over all these years
that we have seen the ups and downs of
incidents and the decline in mortality
we have very consistently year after
year seen a very substantial
racial disparity whereby
african-american men compared to
caucasian men
have consistently born about a two and a
half fold increased burden
not just of prostate cancer diagnosis
but of diagnosis with metastatic and
ultimately lethal
disease and this has really not changed
much year after year decade after decade
from 1970s
uh to the mid-2000s this rate ratio
varied up and down a little bit but
really never
fell substantially even as rates as
mortality rates did
fall among african-american men and
caucasian men the gap really has not
narrowed
very much now as many things in
epidemiology the
the devil is often in the details and
when we drill down
below the national level we actually see
pretty profound variation in these
trends over time
this was a nice study looking at 50
different
urban areas across the u.s comparing
mortality rates from 1990s
to the late 2000s and what this is
looking at
is the change over time for caucasian
men
in the white circles here and
african-american men in the black
circles here
and looking at the delta delta the
difference over time so for example in
san francisco
my city uh there's this is a fairly
typical case where there was about a 44
drop in mortality for for white men 43
drop for black men
so there's a comparable decline but
really no change
in the delta no change in the gap
between between the groups
over the years but you can see some
extreme counter examples in minnesota
for example in minneapolis the mortality
rate fell about 30
for caucasians over 70 percent of
african-americans so here there's a
pretty substantial
narrowing of the gap at the other
extreme in oklahoma city
mortality rates fell about 40 for
caucasians and actually rose 8
for african-american men so substantial
widening of the gap and of course a lot
of this is random variation this is not
you know nobody's saying that there are
specific programs that we can point to
in one city or another
which explain this a lot of this is
statistical noise
but it's still important to really
understand the local patterns
um of where everyone lives and practices
in terms of trying to understand what is
going on in the local populations
now there's a paper that came out just a
couple months ago
again looking at seer data which
suggests
that in the most recent years we may be
seeing a little bit of progress so this
is the
mid-2000s up through the mid 2010s
showing that this rate ratio has been
declining over this
time period from about three to around
2.5
for men 50 to
and for older men we've seen a similar
decline
uh now this may be this may be a true
decline although if you think back to
the graph that i showed earlier the rate
ratio has varied over the years between
two and three so this may just be a
little bit more you know natural
variation
within the consistent range that we've
seen over the decades
now to an extent it seems to be
the case that prostate cancer actually
follows a similar trajectory among
african-american men
as it does among white men but that it
starts about five years earlier
this is a paper from a set of models run
by the cisnet group
this is a group of statistical modelers
funded by the nci
and the the prostate working group who
have been really focused on
nothing but understanding the psa
observed incidence and mortality data
through the lens of screening programs
for nearly 30 years now it's
investigators from
the freight hutch in seattle led by ruth
ozioni by a group in michigan and
uh group in erasmus in rotterdam who
have all been
looking at the observed data through
different mathematical models
and all three models gave a fairly
consistent
output a consistent story that again the
trajectory may be similar but the
onset of prostate cancer the first
growth of the cells and ultimately the
clinical presentation
appears to be about five years earlier
on average
for black men compared to white men and
we see this if we look
at the again look at the the rate ratio
data the increased burden borne by black
men compared to
white men this is looking across time
now
not over time we see that by far the
highest rate ratios are seen for the
younger
men okay so for men in their late 40s
african-american men actually have a
four-fold higher
likelihood of being diagnosed with
metastatic disease compared to caucasian
men
and as men get older the gap narrows and
ultimately flattening out around
a two-fold higher rate of metastatic
disease for men by the time they get to
their 80s
again suggesting that a large
part of the explanation for the excess
burden of disease borne by black men may
be seen in the fact that the disease
starts
earlier and it's really younger
african-american men who are in fact
at greatest excess risk
so nothing that i've said so far is
really at all controversial it's been
widely recognized for
a long time that prostate cancer is
worse among african-american men
african-american men get more prostate
cancer they get more high-risk disease
and ultimately more
lethal disease but none of the data that
none of the studies that i've shown have
really gotten at the important question
which is why
is this cell and there's a nice
framework for
thinking about what health their health
disparity research should look like
which proposes three phases of disparity
research
phase one is identifying that a
disparity exists phase two is
elucidating the underlying causes of the
disparity
and phase three is developing
interventions to try to ameliorate this
disparity
and the fact is we've really been stuck
in phase one pretty much forever
in prostate cancer we are just starting
to dip our toes into phase two
and really have not begun to scratch
what what should ultimately be phase
three so you know what are at the roots
what what can we say in phase two
that that can potentially explain what
we know to be
a very substantial disparity well the
obvious uh potential sources
of of explanation here are genetic
factors environmental factors
and then structural factors which are
basically access to care and the quality
of care delivered now of course there's
multiple
sub levels of investigation here in
terms of environmental factors well it's
an incredibly broad category that
is things like diet smoking allostatic
stressors it's also things like
neighborhood factors
and structural bias within the
healthcare delivery system kind of falls
under access to care
and so are african-american men able to
get screening do they have the right
information about screening
if they get screened do they have access
to high quality urology care and
diagnosis
is treatment done appropriately and is
it
and is it of high enough quality and
then also under the
the access domain are structural issues
such as well-founded mistrust in the
healthcare system
other issues with structural racism in
areas of public health
etc and the problem is most studies tend
to be fairly reductionist they focus
on just genetic factors just
environmental factors just access
factors when in fact the truth is almost
certainly all of the above and it's also
true
that when we look at studies of prostate
cancer incidents
or in particular studies of prostate
cancer mortality
the more factors we put into a
multivariable model
the more likely it is that race itself
will drop out
meaning that we can find the the
explanation here doesn't mean that there
is not a racial disparity it means that
it's really not about
skin color per se and it's probably not
even that much about biology it's about
all the things that go into race as a
social construct
that really drive the excess burden in
terms of
in terms of race for prostate cancer
there may be some
biologic differences uh this is a brief
study that just came out in the journal
recently
looking at some publicly available
genetic data and they did find some
differences across race this was looking
at asian white and
black men in terms of the total
mutational burden actually the highest
burden was seen for asian men here and
you do see some differences in specific
genes if you look
hard enough uh perhaps more actionable
genes although that's
pretty a fairly moving target in terms
of what that that term means
among black compared to white or asian
men
but i don't think any of these data or
similar studies would
support a statement that there's
anything fundamentally different about
the biology of prostate cancer among
black compared to white men there are
some differences here
but they are you know they're relatively
subtle and none of these again would
suggest that we are dealing with
fundamentally a different biology
so there may be an answer to be found in
screening
if you look at the screening guidelines
in 2020
we do see a gradual convergence
over the you know or beyond what has
been
a very controversial and divergent set
of guidelines over the years so the us
preventive services task force which i
mentioned earlier
is by far the most influential body when
it comes to driving
screening decisions and screening
recommendations by primary care
providers to their patients
so in 2012 the uspstf recommended that
nobody should be screened ever
regardless of race or family history or
any of the risk factors
now as of 2018 they recommend shared
decision making for men
55 to 69 and they recommend against
four men over 70. they have no specific
recommendations for african-american men
there's some text in there calling for
uh more research although the prospect
of getting a randomized screening trials
specifically focused on african-american
men
is extremely low and even if such a
study happened we would not get results
for
20 more years and this 50 to 5 to 69
age range here is by the way is not
based on
any evidence to suggest that that is the
optimal time to screen the reason that
age range is recommended
is that there's really only one large
multi-center randomized trial
which actually addresses the question of
screening versus no screening it's the
erspc
a large multinational european trial
which has read out its results over the
years and
in that trial the core age range for
randomization was 55 to 69. so that is
the reason that this
age is is the basis for the uspstf
us psts recommendation it's almost
certainly not optimal there was another
trial which included men 50 to 55 which
actually had better results than the
rspc which was not included here
and it is very likely the case that
screening earlier
makes the most sense so the aua the
american neurological association
now is actually relatively similar to
the uspsdf
in also recommending shared
decision-making for men in the same core
age range 55-70
they don't really make any
recommendations for younger men they
recommend against for older men and
again no specific recommendations for
african-american men
now the other guidelines the nccn and
the american cancer society
are both based on a broader
consideration of literature rather than
focusing just on this
on the randomized trials they recommend
shared decision making again
uh for a broader age range the nccn
recommends for men 45 to 75
acs recommends starting at 50. acs
explicitly recommends starting about
five years earlier if there are risk
factors even 10 years earlier if there's
multiple risk factors including
african-american race so african
americans with family history where you
start to get multiple risk factors this
is where you really want to think about
starting at 40.
the nccn is a little bit less crisp but
they do recommend
starting screenings several years
earlier again for african american
men so what about access you know what
do we actually
see in terms of screening patterns for
black compared to white men
this may actually be a little bit of
good news and these studies have been
done repeatedly over the years you know
the fundamental message here is is still
not great news if you ignore disparity
for a minute which is that the most
common age for screening in america
is still late 60s and early 70s and this
is not the right time to do
screening with psa men by this age tend
to have bph
they tend to have many competing sources
of psa and this is an age where we see a
lot of
over detection of low risk disease under
detection
of high risk disease and ultimately over
treatment
and under treatment as well by far the
best time to use psa is in
late 40s early 50s maybe even up to age
60 where psa with a lower threshold is
much more specific
for prostate cancer specifically and
this may actually be
a bit of good news within this overall
you know problematic screening pattern
which is that black men are actually
more likely to be screened at younger
ages than white men a little bit less
likely to be screened
than white men at older ages so this is
less under screening for younger men
and actually less over screening for
older men so
so this is actually likely a favorable
trend i think reflecting an
understanding over the years that
black men are at higher risk and should
be potentially screened
earlier the problem though is that this
20 30
right here is still much too low and if
we want to make a difference
we probably need to drive these rates up
specifically in the younger age ranges
quite substantially and there is a
rationale to think that
a large portion of the disparity could
be ameliorated with a more aggressive
early detection program directed
specifically
at african american men it's important
to note that when we talk about early
screening
we need to forget all about 4.0 as the
threshold
to drive further evaluations so
4.0 was chosen because one psa was
developed as a screening test
most men in the screening studies were
in their 60s just as
in the study here and the fact is for
younger men for men
even up to age 60 the median is around
1.0 for men in their 40s and 50s
the median is 0.7 or 0.8 and this has
been shown very consistently across
multiple studies
and multiple ethnicities multiple
countries
so the median for men in their 40s
is around 0.6 0.7 in your early 50s
around 0.8 by the time you get to 60
around 1.0 and again this is identical
for white men black men there's a large
study out of japan which again shows
exactly the same
medium psas so what this says
is that with a single psa test before
age 60 we can pretty much
rule out prostate cancer for at least
half the population and probably even
more
these studies summarized here looked at
long-term outcomes after a single
baseline psa going out to
10 20 30 years and found that this
single baseline test was highly highly
predictive
so men under the median or even under
the 75th percentile in many cases can
basically
not worry about prostate cancer but men
above median basically above 1.0 is a
good way to remember it
need to at least think about workup with
secondary tests
not necessarily with biopsy but either
with
with more careful monitoring going
forward or with
workup now what about treatment
do we have evidence of any sort of
bias or discrepancy in terms of access
to high quality treatment
well this is a look at the likelihood of
receiving definitive treatment as
opposed to
no definitive treatment and what we see
is
over the years here from 2004 up to 2013
higher rates of expectant management or
no definitive treatment for
african-american compared to
caucasian men in a large study out of
the national cancer data bank
and now the ncdb is focused really in
hospital
based care so this is going to
under-capture
active surveillance done in the
community setting
and this is not particularly
risk-adjusted so it's a little bit hard
to know but this
is suggestive perhaps of more
under-treatment among african-american
men
there was a study reported last year
using
a new seer sub-database focused on
watchful weighting
which looked at the odds of receiving
active surveillance for
risk prostate cancer for black versus
other men they found variation from year
to year
suggesting in 2008 they concluded in
2015 there was a drop in the use of
surveillance for black men but this was
really an
insufficiently adjusted study and
and a follow-up paper which is going to
be coming out in press
relatively soon shows that with further
adjustment
for other factors like income education
access to health care providers in the
community specific geographic location
black versus white race drops out
completely the hazard ratio here is 0.99
there is really not a hint of a
difference between the two groups if
anything it's actually hispanic men who
have a lower risk
of acting a lower likelihood of active
surveillance to watch for waiting
compared to the other groups
and the other story here is that any
sort of racial
difference is really swamped by just raw
variation this is
looking at the different seer registries
registry by registry
and within the registry is the
individual counties and the county level
variation really swamps everything
and we've known this to be a problem for
many many years in prostate cancer care
and health were in the health care
system
you know what you get depends far too
much on whose door you happen to knock
on in terms of which which doctor you
wind up seeing
and getting at this variation problem
certainly has to be part of the project
in terms of ameliorating
disparity at the level of race and
so the prior analysis raises the
question is the disparity really driven
by race or
is race just reflecting uh poor social
economic
status reflecting structural racism etc
but basically is an economic problem
rather than
a race problem per se
for one look at this we looked years ago
at the san francisco general hospital
population which is the safety net
hospital serving san francisco county
compared to the university practice at
ucsf
and compared to a large registry called
capture which tracked men diagnosed with
prostate cancer
across 25 urology practices across the
united states
and this is a look at the the risk
profile so zero through nine here is
what we call the capri score
low intermediate and high risk prostate
cancers and over here on the right is
advanced disease at the time of
diagnosis
and in short the men presenting at sf
general hospital had a three-fold higher
rate of presenting with events disease
than those
in in the capture database and much
higher likelihoods of intermediate and
high-risk disease despite the average
age being about the same
at the general and the screening rates
psa diagnosis being
being fairly similar but this was true
in a very
mixed race population so the
sf general population certainly has more
black men
than capture or the broader ucsf
population but we saw this
across the asians across the caucasian
patients in this hospital
hispanics it was really seen across all
the different race groups this this high
prevalence
of high risk and advanced disease
now it's also worth stepping back away
from the united states for a minute in
terms of trying to gain some
insights from global epidemiology in
terms of prostate cancer because
prostate cancer is increasingly a global
disease
we used to think of this as a disease
really just affecting men in the
developed world
who would live long enough to not die
from infectious diseases or violent
violent causes malnutrition etc but as
the world is developing it is
more and more of a concern
internationally prostate cancer
is now one of the higher causes
of incidence internationally almost 10
million cases a year
anticipated and it has now passed
esophageal cancer to be the fifth
leading cause of cancer mortality around
the world
and but of course incidence varies
dramatically with geographic
locale now what's interesting is if you
look at the
incidence data they really do tend to
track with screening rates so
the developed world tends to have higher
rates of incidence although there are
certainly hot spots in the caribbean for
example in brazil
south africa where we see exceptions
here but what's interesting is that the
incidence data and the mortality data
have relatively little
association with each other so there are
some countries
sweden for example which screens heavily
but still has a relatively high
mortality rate
the story in the u.s is fairly typical
of what we would hope to see with a
screening program which is heavy
screening
tends to drive down mortality rates
and then if we look for the highest
mortality rates for prostate cancer in
the world
we find them in areas with relatively
little screenings specifically in
sub-saharan and west africa
and in the caribbean we see high
incidence and
mortality and if we look at the highest
mortality rates in the world many of
these countries
are in the caribbean so it's the
combination
we think of countries where there's a
high population of west african origin
and relative economic development
compared to
the actual west african countries so the
men have the opportunity to live long
enough
uh to to potentially get lethal prostate
cancer
and this is really where we're seeing
these these rates which are
truly off the chart if you compare them
to the u.s where the age standardized
mortality rate is is about 7.7
we're seeing rates as high as seven
times uh
that rate when we look at some of these
jamaican some of these caribbean
countries and again the
there is a little bearing here little
association consistently between
development index
um and mortality rates
uh this is just one more look at the at
this association or poor association
lack of association between incidents
and mortality
so we know that environmental factors
bear heavily on
prostate cancer incidence and mortality
prostate cancer has been associated
quite clearly with smoking rates
with certain poor dietary habits
high inflammatory diet high fat diets
have been associated with prostate
cancer
there's also the question about stress
and cancer there's there's very poor
or weak data here for prostate cancer
specifically
but there have been uh some at least in
vitro studies
in mice and cell lines uh the mice this
is
a classic example of just stressing out
the mice by putting them
just in crowded living conditions
crowded cages the same mice tend to get
more
cancer now this is this concept of
allostatic stress
many of us are lead stressful lives a
lot of things going on in life
um but i'm guessing that most of you
watching this video like myself
and if i quit my job tomorrow i wouldn't
starve and my children would not
lose the roof over their heads and that
is not the kind of stress
that we think is is carcinogenic it's
the allostatic stress
of day in day out uncertainty as to
one's uh
security and future that we really think
are
are bad you know the elevated
chronically elevated cortisol levels and
arrangement of various genomic pathways
inflammatory cascades
none of which is all that well defined
are likely factors
to be considered and certainly need much
much better
study so finally the question has come
up whether african-american men should
be offered active surveillance which
means
not treating aggressively immediately at
the time of diagnosis and this
controversy has been raised i alluded to
this before with the treatment data
and this really i came up with a couple
of studies out of johns hopkins
which found that if you take
african-american men with low-risk
disease and look
who went straight to surgery and look at
the likelihood of finding
more aggressive cancer at the at the
time of surgical pathology
uh these likelihoods were much much
higher for african-american men compared
to caucasian men about five-fold
higher likelihood of adverse pathology
and they're four and a half fold and
this was even after adjustment for
other factors and a follow-up paper
suggests that african-american men have
more anterior tumors which are more
likely to be missed by prostate biopsies
because those are typically done
trans-rectally
so through the recommend to the
peripheral zone of the prostate here
the problem is this has really not been
validated in other studies so we looked
at the ucsf cohort and at the capture
study
which admittedly has a relatively small
proportion of african-american men
and found that if we looked at upgrading
up staging there was really
no impact of race once we adjusted for
other factors there was a slightly
higher rate of positive margins but that
is not really the same
the same finding as as what hopkins
showed we also looked in the search
registry which is a multi-va registry
with a much higher proportion of
african-american men about 40
and again adjusting for other factors
race drops out of the model
doesn't mean that african-american men
don't have worse disease it just means
that that disease
is adequate that that increased risk is
adequately captured
by the standard parameters like gleason
score psa
margin status etc and for
african-american men that actually start
on active surveillance again the hopkins
data
did show an increased risk of
reclassification to higher grade disease
about one and a half fold
higher risk but hazard ratio which again
has not been replicated
in other cohorts this is the
multi-center canary cohort
which found that race dropped out again
with
adequate adjustment so what explains
this we don't really know
and this really goes to the point again
i've alluded to this a couple times in
the talk that race is really a social
construct not a biological one and we
say you know we use the term
african-american
for a wide wide range of genetic
and genomic heritage uh even looking at
the mean proportion of african ancestry
across the country
you see huge huge ranges and of course
africa is a big place and specific
heritage
within africa will drive different
genetic risk potentially if genetics
explain
at least a part of the of the disparity
so maybe there is something unique about
the the population around baltimore
served by johns hopkins perhaps it's
just a statistical fluke
certainly something that bears further
investigation
and the final comment when we look at
distal endpoints meaning
actual cancer-specific mortality
we again find across multiple registries
this is seer this is a set of different
randomized trials
multi-center va cohort that with
adjustment african-american race tends
to drop
out of the models again not to say that
the disparity is not very much real
but only that it is that the increased
risk is reflected we can find it
in the standard disease characteristics
so to sum up there is no question that
african-american men face much higher
rates of prostate cancer
both in terms of incidence and mortality
the explanations
remain really poorly understood they are
almost certainly multifactorial
reflecting some combination which we
still do not understand of genetic
environmental and health system factors
and it's the interactions among these
factors that are really crucial to
understand
but we really need to recognize that the
disparity is certainly more than
just skin deep and if we want to
eliminate the observed racial disparity
we probably have
to address more than a single factor
and there is again no argument that
african-american men face earlier
mortality and should be offered
screening
likely at an earlier starting age 45 is
probably a reasonable target
using a threshold of 1.0 at that age to
merit for the workup or at least
closer surveillance but again after
diagnosis race tends to drop out of most
these models
which is reassuring at least to the
extent that the parameters that we know
predict outcomes like psa gleason score
stage etc
are no less germane to african-american
men as they are for caucasian men so
this is an area of
both substantial clinical importance
social importance and also
an area really really ripe for high
quality research going forward
and we really look forward to the future
developments here so
thank you very much for your attention
and i hope to
see you at a future session